[Music]
hey guys I'm Courtney says no here with
the cast of blackish at the step up
inspiration Awards let's talk about this
backdoor pilot that was right before the
season finale we say you go off to
college yeah I mean it's art imitating
life imitating art I don't have to
imagine this because this is my life so
you are using white guilt for your
college essay yes
aha okay well someone's getting into
college yeah you had until May first to
finally come into a school in real life
do you know where you're going now I do
okay can we share a school which um I
committed to Harvard and I'm really
excited congratulations
so I'm sure Michelle Obama is heads of
Peru she gave me that recommendation I
wrote the recommendation letters no he
didn't um I have to say I'm really
excited with my AP calc teacher wrote me
a recommendation letter
now's the only student she wrote a
recommendation letter and honor yeah and
so I was very happy I have I'm I don't
have it framed but I'm gonna get it read
it and then have it framed right I'm so
glad we're staying in the dorm mrs.
Obama is proud and Tracy as a brown
graduate was very disappointed and yet
and yet so proud about this Harvard now
I got an oh did you guys all it was that
the choice for the entire blackish cast
or you were happy with whatever kind of
room for Cal State Fullerton I want to
keep it close yeah yours very smart so
that's why you guys are these good
decisions we support this so the
showrunner did have me in the vo booth
and wouldn't like let me out until he
gave me the pitch on Brown John yeah
there's a lot of Brown alums on our show
some of it 11 I wrap gifts were like
you're a great season go to brown you're
a great but I'm excited what you're with
your choice I gotta know though how much
influence are we gonna see oncologist of
your real life because I mean you're
doing everything girl you're an activist
you're in your style influence well Zoe
and I are very
different people and so I respecting
that and I hope that we just see growth
from her I know there are moments in
which her inner Yara comes out in their
moments in which my inner Zoey comes out
what I can't promise anything if you
have a sneak peak on a script can you
let me know I will let you know if Kenya
lets me know I will let you know okay
are you gonna be in the college is
spin-off can we see you crashing campus
and embarrassing Zoey oh I can see it I
could see it um who knows junior goes
off to college very soon as everyone
knows so I don't know where ever where
the writers place me that's where I go
so let's see where it takes me
[Music]
you